he's the samurai warrior of silicon
valley
larry's attitude is if you want to
compete against me then be prepared to
be crushed
larry ellison started oracle software
over 30 years ago
and it has made him the highest paid
executive over the last decade
with a total compensation of 1.84
billion dollars
there was nobody better than larry at
making a customer believe that he could
change that person's business life with
his product
he sees around the corner well before
many of us get to the end of the street
he'll do whatever it takes to win in the
office
sap the german software firm was ordered
to pay oracle
1.3 billion dollars or on the ocean
there is absolutely no doubt that he
hates to lose
his company's technology has become the
backbone of the world's information
systems from government to online
commerce
the brazen billionaire is an ambitious
provocateur
with a singular management style i have
a theory that
larry's succession plan for oracle is he
is trying to figure out a way that when
he's
six feet under in a grave he can still
run oracle
[Music]
[Applause]
loud and clear okay
if you know anything about oracle's
larry ellison it probably goes something
like this
i've got a bugatti the fastest car in
the world this home costs 200 million
dollars the fastest sailboat that's ever
been built
i'm addicted to winning the more you win
the more you want to win he's a high
flying adrenaline junkie
and an unapologetic collector of
expensive toys and real estate
he spent 400 million dollars to bring
the 2010 america's cup
the oldest active trophy in sports back
to america
for the first time in 15 years
[Applause]
but his success comes from something far
less flashy
some of the world's most essential
software
tools you use every day but probably
don't realize that it's his company
making them work
[Music]
almost everybody in the world uses
oracle they just don't know it
if you do any kind of government
transaction with almost any government
in the world
any business transaction with almost any
internet business in the world or any
traditional business
if you have a credit card if you have a
cell phone if you have any of the
the modern things in life if you live
today i think you probably use oracle
larry ellison arguably created the most
important computer software you never
heard of he was the man behind the
curtain for a tremendous change in the
way we all live
ellison remained behind that curtain
when we tried to reach him to
participate in this program
born in the bronx in 1944 ellison grew
up in chicago
when he was 12 his father bluntly gave
him some surprising news
my dad just said right before dinner oh
by the way you were adopted and we're
having meatloaf tonight
it was so shocking i just put it away
and thought about it
for years without really you know
confronting all
and realizing all of the implications he
dropped out of college
twice ellison was a mediocre student and
disliked formal education
mike wilson is an editor for the saint
petersburg times
and interviewed ellison extensively for
his biography
larry was not interested in following
the rules at school
in the family or anywhere else larry
needed to get out from underneath the
shadow of louis ellison
and prove to his father that he could
make something of himself
his flair for the fast lane was obvious
early
larry went out and bought himself a
turquoise blue thunderbird he was a
stylish guy
he wanted to impress people he got in
that car and he drove it to california
larry ellison was a young man with a
great deal of potential his trip to
california was
critical to who he would become
ellison settled in berkeley and set out
to make a living writing code
in 1973 he worked at the computer
electronics maker
amdahl there he met stuart fagan they've
remained friends for over 35 years
i went into my cubicle the first day i
worked there and across the hall
were a couple guys who never seemed to
do any work they just talked all the
time
and one of them did nothing but talk
about himself how smart he was
how stupid everyone else was and how he
really ought to be running everything
and that was larry ellison ellison was a
talented but impatient programmer
desperate to find something of his own
to control
to say he he had the attention span of a
tumbleweed
is to overestimate it i would say more
the attention span of a lightning bolt
but his attention focused when he landed
a job at a company called
ampex ampex was struggling with a
project funded by
of all places the information-driven cia
the project was codenamed oracle
the cia needed a system to store and
retrieve
vast amounts of foreign intelligence
concerned with its various sensitive
operations and missions
for ellison it was the job of a lifetime
and would plant the seeds for his future
in the 1970s
information storage meant putting data
on reel to reel tape
which was just too slow and inconsistent
for the cia
and too slow for ellison he left ampex
and
later started his own company with his
friend and programming genius
bob miner bob and larry were a perfect
odd couple for
silicon valley bob had all of the
engineering smarts
the technical ability larry on the other
hand had the sales ability
the visionary ability the ability to go
to a customer and explain
here's how your business can change with
this original handwritten sign
and twelve hundred dollars they started
software development laboratories
or sdl ellison recruited friends at
oates and stuart fagan
to help program he did want me to join
him
and he's going to start some kind of
company and i thought that was the
stupidest
idea i'd ever heard because larry wasn't
famous for finishing things
i used to say he's a total flake and
will never amount to anything and i was
half right
ellison's new company needed a product
and after reading an obscure ibm
research paper
he thought he had it a method of sorting
information that was vastly superior to
anything that had come
before it was called a relational
database
according to gary bloom who worked with
ellison for 14 years
it was a complex name but a simple idea
relational database what you know what
it what is it it's a collection of data
and information
that's very simply put into a format
that makes it very easy to search and
find that information
it's nothing more complicated than that
ibm didn't see the potential of what
they had
ellison did i said oh my god we can beat
ibm to market
because ibm doesn't believe in their own
idea
ellison believed and asked programmer
bruce scott
to start writing code for me it's just
cool technology and kind of fun but for
larry you know he saw a company out of
it he saw a market out of it
we weren't sure larry was right but we
needed the jobs
and it was a struggle all the time larry
was was
under a lot of pressure to get some
money in somehow
in 1977 at age 34
larry ellison's startup software company
was busy creating a smart database
they thought would revolutionize how
companies retrieve
manage and analyze data three rooms
and a little lobby area there were four
of us who were writing programs
larry was mostly involved in finding
customers
and that was a bizarre idea because we
had no software
so all the things that you would read in
books of somebody being a leader he
wasn't
but he was tenacious he would never give
up on anything
alison chased and cajoled customers
becoming the company's chief evangelist
there was nobody better than larry at
making a business person making a
customer believe that
he could change that person's business
life with his product
knowing they still needed a smarter
solution for the monumental task of
managing worldwide intelligence
ellison sold his database to the cia his
first customer
he called the new software oracle
version two
there was no version one because
everyone thought uh well no one buys
version one it's buggy so we started
with version two
well our version two was at least as
buggy as anyone's version one and i
described those early versions as
the roach motel of databases the data
went in but it didn't come out
in 1982 ellison also took the name
oracle for his company
he targeted government agencies and
major corporations
in his own unique way i remember him
telling me very distinctly one time
bruce
we can't be successful unless we lie to
customers for some reason
larry told the bank of america i think
he told us there were 15 of us
when in fact there were five of us i'm
not sure why the bank of america would
think differently
of you if you're 5 or 15 but
larry had given them a number which was
a little larger than reality
ellison also was sharpening a sales
philosophy rooted in a trip he had taken
to japan
in the early 1970s i was in japan and i
was talking to a japanese business
executive
and he told me uh
you know that that the problem with
america is that we just have no stomach
for competition
in japan we believe our competitors are
stealing the rice out of the mouths of
our
you know of our children in japan we
think anything less than 100 market
share is not enough
his take no prisoners approach became
known as the oracle way
the oracle way in the early to mid 80s
was
just to win almost by any means
necessary
larry's attitude is if you want to
compete against me
then you better be prepared to be
crushed or don't compete against me
his product the oracle database took off
like a jet fighter in one of his ads
and in 1986 oracle went public
his 39 stake in the company was worth a
stunning 93 million dollars
the ipo was a huge hit but was
overshadowed the very next day
by microsoft's public offering which
made bill gates stake worth
a whopping 350 million dollars
in 1989 ellison moved oracle to this
mammoth campus in redwood shores
california which became known as
the emerald city a reference to the
wizard of oz
or as one newspaper described it larry
land
and everyone knew who was the wizard
when i
ordered a ferrari 348 and i was going to
get the first
348 in california larry ordered one
from somewhere on the east coast and got
it shipped in before i got mine
he didn't want to be the second one he
wanted to be the first one
his obsession to be first took its toll
oracle hit a wall these aggressive sales
practices
started to cause serious problems
oracle's aggressive sales practices in
the 80s
turned the company into an accountant's
nightmare
the salesforce was so aggressive so
willing to close a deal
and there were so few business controls
over the makeup of those deals
then we started having the problem of we
certainly signed some bad contracts
they were also selling products that
hadn't yet been created
oracle was selling a lot of futures so
you're taking a lot of money and a lot
of revenue in for future deliverables
well then the question comes when you
finally have those deliverables now who
do you sell them to
you already sold it to everybody you
sold it to him three years before you
had it
it didn't help the company's prospects
that their latest product was a dud
oracle version 6 was riddled with bugs
customers were frustrated and sales
plummeted
it's sometimes characterized as the
near-death experience of oracle
in the early 90s and it was we weren't
cutting fat
we're cutting into muscle and you might
even say we're in a couple cases we're
cutting a couple limbs off
with oracle's stock price and freefall
so was ellison's personal fortune
by november 1st 1990 he had lost
790 million dollars his company was
nearly a billion dollar operation
and it was failing larry was trying to
achieve this greatness
he was building towards that all the
time and now
he was in a sense of laughing stock it
was devastating for him
we're all a bunch of kids that grew up
with the business and we weren't kids
anymore and the business wasn't a little
business anymore
it was big business and we had to
replace virtually all of senior
management
and it was a very painful process he
convinced well-known management and
sales consultant
ray lane to join the company and what he
brought was what i'd characterize as
operational discipline
and a maturity around this is how a big
business runs
it was chaotic it was painful nobody
wanted to go through that again
and so the culture was kind of reset
but the company's real savior came in
the form of a new
product zach nelson was oracle's
youngest marketing executive
oracle 7 was a spectacular product the
future was
incredibly bright and i think everybody
within oracle at that time
certainly knew it and can sense it it
wasn't just incrementally better it was
orders of magnitude better
[Music]
ellison's company had dodged its
near-death experience
in 1994 oracle revenues passed the two
billion dollar mark
and his stock as a result was worth
nearly three billion dollars
for ellison that wasn't nearly enough to
become
software sole heavyweight ellison knew
he had to pick a fight with the reigning
champion
bill gates she seemed to be personally
disappointed he wasn't wealthier than
bill gates it's the score card
and if you weren't number one if you
weren't richest you weren't on the top
you weren't the best
it was the score card and he was losing
i think that larry thought he was in a
tremendous
competition with bill gates and and
maybe gates didn't think so so much
larry wanted to be recognized as the
greatest
innovator salesman evangelist in the
world of software
and he had a steep battle going up
against the guy who had put his software
in every single personal computer
practically in the world
[Music]
alison was fixated on gates he would
later admit publicly to hiring private
detectives to dig up dirt on him
gates new product windows 95 had the
entire tech world buzzing
including ellison himself in this
appearance on the charlie rose show
this windows 95 is an enormously
complicated piece of software
and the idea that people are going to
install this in their households and
manage these things in their household
to me is hilarious and it's time for
something that's easier to use well this
is clearly part of our strategy to throw
in microsoft
but the way you throw on microsoft is
not somebody you know to throw darts at
bill gates and hate and envy bill gates
you have to think of think about
products and create products
that are better than the products that
microsoft is selling
ellison made a move into the consumer
device market
he called it the network computer or nc
he launched the network computer with
great fanfare the computers we currently
make personal computers
are rather expensive right very very
complex
so we've introduced this new classic
computer and for normal human beings
it's
very light that's pretty very low cost
very lightweight now
every person can use a computer because
they're low cost and very easy to use
you can surf the net you can do email on
and he said and it's gonna be 500 kind
of an internet appliance
so to speak no different than your
toaster i can remember having a
discussion with him
saying you know the internet makes it
possible to imagine
a world without microsoft's operating
system on every desktop
and that was really you know the birth
of the nc ellison went on a campaign to
promote the power of his new baby
on the web while mocking the popular pc
i hate the pc with a passion put the
stuff
on the net it's bits don't put bits in
cardboard
cardboard and trucks trucks to stores me
yeah
me go to the store you know pick this
stuff out it's insane
i love the internet but
falling pc prices meant the nc was
destined to fail
i don't think there's anything wrong
with the idea i actually just think it
was premature
five years later would have won the
world and the only difference is
all the pc manufacturers dell hp
everybody else gateway
what did they do they created a 500 pc
that surfs the web really well and it
does email really well
and that shut down ellison's venture
into the consumer market
his nc was too far ahead of its time
but his vision of the internet was still
right on target
oracle's database became the
underpinnings of all of these
internet services that we take for
granted today expedia
amazon ebay go down the list of
applications
all those are storing all that
information retrieving that information
delivering that information doing those
transactions
through the oracle database people
thought larry was crazy
now he's a genius kind of solved the
biggest i.t problem in history
by 2000 larry ellison's company oracle
was among the elite tech companies in
the world
but internal struggles would soon force
out the company's president and chief
operating officer
ray lane who had risen to second in
command and heir apparent
he described the culture at the company
he left
it wasn't good enough for a salesman to
make their quota they had to make
200 of their quota it was
you know the top 10 percent get rewarded
millions and everybody else
you know falls by the website their weak
soldiers shoot them
a departing lane said he didn't fit into
oracle's system
and that the only person making
decisions at oracle is larry
lots of people that transitioned in and
out of oracle got confused who was in
charge
and that's a pretty volatile that's like
a galactic collision
yeah where two stars hit and it's a
pretty violent explosion
oracle the company was on a roll but was
lagging behind
in one key area we're still fighting to
be
relevant in the applications world we're
the number two application provider in
the world and we're number two in erp
behind sap boy this number two is
getting old and we're number two
not for one we're number two we're
number two in uh crm behind siebel but
we're growing faster than sap
and we're growing faster than siebel and
we're determined to become number one in
applications that's like we're number
one in database
to get to number one ellison needed to
do something his company had
long avoided buying new technology
through acquisitions when he came to
that conclusion
he opened his wallet and bet bit far
bigger than anyone else
did and in fact he did it far faster
than anyone else did
ellison wanted to bundle new application
software with oracle's successful
product line
in 2003 he targeted the company
peoplesoft in a hostile takeover attempt
the department of justice sued oracle on
anti-trust grounds
charging the takeover would empower the
company to illegally raise rates and
impair innovation
after a year and a half long battle the
courts sided with oracle
ellison finally acquired peoplesoft for
10.3
billion dollars it's very rare that
someone
gets sued by the government and they
actually win
you know i mean it's just another
testament to this guy's tenacity most
guys would have maybe walked away from
that
instead ellison stepped it up over the
next five years he would spend close to
34 billion dollars acquiring 52
companies
heather bellini is senior managing
director of the technology research team
at international strategy and investment
group
she has covered oracle since 2003. he
started looking out and seeing how the
landscape was
was changing and how the carnage that
was done
to some of his competitors was going to
give him an opportunity to go make some
acquisitions
and buy some technology where he was
behind
and he really was the one that started
the whole
m a trend within the technology industry
ellison's appetite for acquisitions
accelerated in 2009
with his 7.4 billion dollar trophy
purchase
of the prominent hardware company sun
microsystems
but in 2010 his eyes were on another
trophy
a decade-long 400 million obsession
bmw oracle racing was launched in 2000
for ellison's run at the americas cup it
may be the oldest active prize in
international sport but what ellison
created
was entirely new the boat is a trimaran
it often appears to be nearly flying
with only one of its three holes
actually in contact with the water
[Music]
the oceans have never seen anything like
it
there is absolutely no doubt that he
hates to lose
there is no doubt of that at all grant
dalton has competed
against ellison on the america's cup
circuit my recollection in racing
against him and we will race against him
in the future
this is a man that's very determined to
win
on valentine's day 2010 ellison
brought the america's cup back to the
united states for the first time
in 15 years he celebrated with his now
ex-wife
romance novelist melanie craft it was
his fourth marriage
the old samurai warrior reemerged when
his friend mark hurd resigned as ceo
at hewlett-packard amid allegations of
sexual harassment
and expense account irregularities
ellison
was outraged he attacked the hp board of
directors
he said quote the hp board just made the
worst personnel decision since the
idiots
on the apple board fired steve jobs many
years ago
exactly one month later allison stunned
the business world
when he turned around and hired the
ousted executive
the silicon valley soap opera continued
when hp
named leo apotaker as its chief
executive
his former company sap is oracle's
biggest rival
in business software sap and oracle had
been locked in a nasty
three-year copyright infringement case
that ended in november 2010.
sap the german software firm was ordered
to pay oracle 1.3
billion dollars it was the biggest
settlement ever
for software piracy larry ellison's
brawl had drawn new blood
on the information technology
battlefield and as always
he is more determined than ever to win
larry ellison
is pretty similar to the new york
yankees they're the team
you love to hate and as a competitor to
larry ellison i'm sure that he's the
person
that people love to hate just given how
successful he's been
while most visionaries you think are
sort of just talking off their hat
and saying oh this is how the world can
be you know larry sees how the world can
be
and then he actually tries to make it
that
[Music]
he started with a 1200 stake in a little
company
and by sheer force of will and
persuasion he built it into
one of the giant software companies of
the world